[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها في
ابرز العناوين
البرلماني
اوكرانيا تنتقدوا طبق الغرب في ارسال
دبابات قتاليه ولكن يوافق في تحذيراته من
حرب النووي
قواته تسيطر على بلده كشفكا على اطراف
ضخمه وهجمات دراسيه لتطويق شمالي دوناتس
نهائي خليجي 25 في موعده بعد السيطره على
زخم الجماهير وعوده الهدوء لمحيط ملعب
جذعنا
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه صوت
البرلمان الاوروبي في اجتماعه اليوم لصالح
قرار يدعو الى تصنيف الحرس الثوري منظمه
الارهابيه
كما صوت ايضا لادراج المرشد الاعلى
والرئيس الايراني ابراهيم الرئيسي اضافه
الى المدعي العام محمد منتظر على قوائم
العقوبه
البرلمان الاوروبي طالب باحاله ملف
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في ايران الى مجلس
الامن وادانا بشده اعمال التعذيب والعنف
وانتزاع الاعترافات بالقوه في السجون
الايرانيه
رئيسه البرلمان الاوروبيه روبرت اميتسولا
جددت مطالبه ايران بوقف القمع والغاء
عقوبه الاعدام وقالت ميتسولا ان اعدام
المتظاهرين المطالبين بالحريه
والديمقراطيه في ايران لا يمكن ان يستمر
وطالبت النظام بوقف قمع المحتاجين واسقاطي
احكام الاعدام الصادره ضدهم
مباشره الى بروكسيل ومراسل العربيه نور
الدين الفريدي الذي يتابع هذا الموضوع نور
اهلا وسهلا بك فقط في نشرح للمشاهدين نور
هل يعتبر قرار البرلمان الاوروبي هذا
النافذه ام لا هو مجرد راي استشاري او
قرار استشاري والقرار يعود الى المجلس
الاعلى للاتحاد الاوروبي يقرر
فعلا هو راي استشاري لان البرلمان
الاوروبي لا يمتلك صلاحيات فيها في مجال
السياسه الخارجيه يظلوا الموقف موقف سياسي
ولكن الاشاره السياسيه قويه جدا في هذا
الظرف بالذات سواء لانها تمثل عنصر ضغط
سياسي على الحكومات الاوروبيه هي رساله في
اتجاه ايران مغزى هذه الرساله التي اجمعت
حولها مختلف الكتل السياسيه سواء كان
باستهداف خامنائي ومن معه من المحيطين
والرئيس او باستهديه في الحرس الثوري
والحارس السوري ليس بمجرد ميليشيا او قوه
غير شبه نظاميه او غير نظاميه انما همم
يعني ركيزه من ركائز النظام الاسلامي في
في ايران
هذه هذا القرار مما لا شك فيه ان جوزيه
بورين سيد طلع عليه سيقرؤه جيدا سيستخدمه
في المباحثات مع امير عبد الحياني المشكله
هنا او الاختلاف هنا ان قرار البرلمان
يعني تقريبا الدعوه الى قطيعه تامه النظام
الايراني بينما الدبلوماسيه لها وسائلها
ومنهجيه عملهاوتها هي تختلف تماما عن
المواقف السياسيه البرلمانيه نور في احد
المتابعين يسال ما هي الاليه الان بعد
التصويت البرلمان همم الاوروبي يعني همم
خصوصا بالنسبه للمجلس التنفيذي للاتحاد
الاوروبي وهل هنالك توزيع ادوار بمعنى انه
البرلمان ياخذ هذا القرار ولكن المجلس
التنفيذ الاعلى الاتحاد الاوروبي يكبح ولا
ياخذ بهذا القرار وكما قلت انت فقط وسيله
الضغط على ايران
يعني القرار موجود كان راي استشاري ولكن
في هذا الظرف هذا راي حظ باغلبيه مطلقه
تقريبا
700 نائب صوتوا لهذا القرار لكن عندما
سيتحدث مع امير عبد الله يقول له بانه
هناك اجماع اوروبي حول ضروركي ان توقفوا
هذا سياسه القمعيه هناك على حول الطاوله
هناك مثلا المانيا التي تدعو قول
الاوروبيه المانيا على سبيل المثال هولندا
جمهوريه تشك هذه الدول تقول بادراجي جهاز
الحرس الثوري بالتالي هناك دول متردده همم
الماني ستقول ان البرلمان الاوروبي ان
الشعوب الاوروبيه ان الراي العام الاوروبي
ان الكتل السياسيه الهامه في في هذه
القاره تطالب بادراجه هذا الجهاز ضمن همم
هل هل تخشى من اوروبا من رد فعل ايراني
وزير الخارجيه الايراني قال انه في حال
قررت اوروبا ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه الارهاب فانه كمن يكون يطلق
النار على نفسه وان ايران سترد بقوه
يعني امير عبد الحياني يفترض ان يكون اكثر
تواضع لان بماذا بماذا تهدد ايران اوروبا
وهي قليله وخاصه عن طريق السوق السوداء
وبالتالي هذا ثانوي جدا ايران يمكن ان
تقول ان تنفض يديها من الاتفاق النووي هذه
مشكله للايرانيين انفسهم قبل ان تكون
مشكله لاوربا وانا ذكي مشكله للعالم
وبالتالي هناك حلول اخرى تطرح لمعالجه
برنامج الايراني هي ليست بحلول اوروبيه
ولكن اوروبا
ماتتجد نفسها في وضع تدعم حلولا اخرى غير
الدبلوماسيه همم لمعالجه مشكله البرنامج
النوويه الايراني يمكن لايران ان تفتح
ابواب المخدرات التي تمر من افغانستان الى
الى روسيا الى اوروبا الى تركيا هذه هناك
نوع من التعاون الامني بين الاوروبينا
وايران في هذا الشان وبالتالي اوراق الضغط
الاوروبيه عفوا الايرانيه محدوده للغايه
طيب مقارنه مع الاوراق التي ساكتفي نعم
نور ساكتفي بهذا القدر من بروكسل نور
الدين الافريقي دائما شكرا جزيلا لك نور
على كل هذه المتابعه
عزفت طبول الحرب في اوكرانيا قويا اليوم
على نغمه جديده
للغرب بتشريع ارسال الدبابات وانظمه
الدفاع الجوي قابلتها بتهديد قد ينقل
الصراع الى مرحله جديده وخطيره ومع
اجتماعي وزراء دفاع دول غربيه مع نظيره من
الامريكي في قاعده رمش تايم بالمانيا لبحث
تسريحه اوكرانيا قالت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
انها لا تملك وقتا بينما العالم يسمح
باطاله
ضروره ارسال دبابات الى اوكرانيا
قال للجيش الاسباني ان ذلك لم يتم سريعا
لان الاوكرانيين بحاجه الى التدريب
المانيا كانت قد رفضت السماحه لحلفائها
بتصدير دباباتها الى اوكرانيا او ارسال
انظمتها الخاصه ما لم توافق الولايات
المتحده على ارسال دباباتها اولا
وبحسب صحيفه جورنال نقلا عن مسؤولين
المانيا كبار فان تصدير اعداد كبيره من
الدبابات الحديثه امر قاومته الولايات
المتحده وحلفاء اوكرانيا الاوروبيون منذ
فتره طويله واذا حدث الان فسيمثل تصعيدا
ملحوظا في الدعم الغربي
بالقلق منذ فتره طويله من ان مثل هذه
الخطوه قد تجر البلاد الى مواجهه مباشره
مع روسيا وفقا الصحيفه الامريكيه
هذا وقال المستشار الالماني اولاف شولدس
ان بلاده متشابكه استراتيجيا مع الاصدقاء
والشركاء عندما يتعلق الامر باتخاد قرارات
بشان كيفيه دعم اوكرانيا بما في ذلك
الدبابه
معي من برلين مراسلات العربيه راغده من
المتابعه لهذا الموضوع رغد اهلا وسهلا بك
هل وافقت فعلا برلين على امداد اكياف
بدبابات ليوبار ام لا صحيح ما تقوله صحيفه
برلين معارضه تماما ما لم يتم تزويدها
بدبابات ابرامز امريكيه
بالفعل وهذا ما يبدو بانه المستشار
الالماني والعفشانس ابلغ به الرئيس
الامريكي جيبايدن في اتصال هاتفي يعني
تكلم خلاله عن هذا الامر قبل يومين ابلغ
اطراف الحكومه او الوزراء داخل حكومته
بحسب نتناقلت صحف المانيه اليوم بانه هذا
كان هو الشرط الذي تفرده المانيا بهدف
ارسال هذه الدبابات الحديثه جدا الكيف
ولكن الان يبدو بانه يعني هناك امل كبيره
يعني يعول عليها ربما الشرك الغربي
همم حاله زياره لويد اوستن وزير الدفاع
الامريكي ليبرلين لانه اليوم التقى صباحا
بوزير الدفاع الالماني ولكن ايضا التقى
باهم شخص في المانيا يتخذ الان قرارات
تسليح كياف هو الذي يقود المستشارين
الالمانيه
كان هناك لقاء محضر بين الرجلين ويريد على
ما يبدو بحسب نتناقلت يعني مصادر همم
امريكيه بانه يريد اعرف الامريكي همم
اقناع الالمان بارسال هذه الدبابات دبابات
لابرد الى اوكرانيا همم ما اذا كان يحمل
همم اوستن همم طرح جديد غير ان ترسل
واشنطن دباباتها الامريكيه تصنع غير معروف
ولكن هناك امال على الاقل يعلقها البعض
على ان يصدرها كذا قرار همم يوم غد خلال
او بعد اجتماع رمشتاين الذي سيراسه اصلا
وتعلن المانيا ربما
يعني اقصى ما يمكن جيد نعم
همم يعني الذي تتابعينه وهل يعني البعض
يقول انه لا يعني الالمان لا يريدون
التورت اكثر وبالتالي يتخذون من الدبابات
الابره رمز سريعه لعدم همم الدبابات
[موسيقى]
من دون شك بانه الالمان لا يريدون تصعيد
الحرب اكثر ومن الواضح كان من كلام رئيس
وزراء بولندا اليوم تعليقا على وزير
الدفاع الجديد هو وصفه بانه شخص مقرب جدا
من غير اشترودر الذي يراس خط مشروع نورس
ستريم وهو مقرب جدا من الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين يعني هذا هو الانطباع
الاول عن وزير الدفاع الالماني لدى حلفاء
يعني لدى الحلفاء الغربيين هنا بانه ربما
هذا الوزير الدفاع لم يتمكن ايضا من ان
يخطئ هذه الخطوه الاضافيه المطالبه
المانيا بها ولكن من جهه اخرى ايضا يعني
هو ينتظر الطرف الامريكي يقول البعض انه
همم تحجج واحد لانه الاطراف الاخرى مثلا
بريطانيا وفرنسا كلاما اعلنتها بانه متى
ترسلان دبابات محليه الصنع بريطانيه
وفرنسيه وبالتالي لم يعد امام شارلز ذريعه
بانه الحلفاء الاخرون لم يرسل او لم
يتعهدوا بارسال دبابات محليه الصنع
لذلك من دون شك ضغطه تزايد كنت اقول بانه
محليا ايضا من حلفاء داخل الحكومه الحزب
اللي بيرالي واحده من يعني اهم النواب في
هذا الحزب الذي تراس لجنه الدفاع داخل
البندقيه كانت تقول اليوم يجب ان نتخذها
كذا قرار وامل بان يخرج هكذا قرار يوم
شكرا لك همم راغده بنام كنت معي من برلين
على كل هذه المتابعه
مجموعه الاتصال الدفاعيه الاوكرانيا
المؤلفه من 50 دوله تجتمع في قاعده
رانشتاين الجويه الامريكيه في المانيا
الاتفاق على حزمه جديده وكبيره من
المساعدات العسكريه
مسالته ارسال دبابات ليوبارد الالمانيه
وموافقه برلين على صادرات ان- من دوله
ثالثه الى اوكرانيا ستكون وحيده من
الموضوعات الرئيسيه مع عملي ديفلوماسيين
اوروبيين بان تسمح المانيا للحلفاء بارسال
تلك الدبابات
شغل
هذه القضيه
فسركاؤها في الائتلاف حزب الخضر
والديموقراطيون الاحرار يفضلون ارسال
الدبابات الى اوكرانيا بينما كثيرون في
الحزب الاشتراكيه الديمقراطيه للميول
اليساريه بما فيهم المستشار نفسه كانه
مترددين مده فتره طويله خاصه وان الولايات
المتحده ترفض رساله دبابات ابرامز الخاصه
بها
المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه ديميتر
بتسكوف قال ان كيف ترى في روسيا والرئيس
بوتين مشكله كبيره كما حسب سكوف الرئيس
الاوكراني غولدن على الاصراع بمراعاه
مطالب روسيا وعلى الادراك سريعا بان بوتين
وروسيا موجودان وسيبقى الامر كذلك مشيرا
الى انه ستتم تلبيه مطالب روسيا بطريقه او
باخرى
الكرملين اعلن ان تحذيرات الرئيس الروسي
السابق ونائب سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي دي
متر ميدفاريف من الحرب النوويه تتوافق
تماما مع العقيده النوويه الروسيه كما
اشار لكرمني الى ان اوكرانيا ستظهر قريبا
او ستظهر قريبا رغبتها في تلبيه المطالب
الروسيه محضرا في ذات الوقت اوكرا يعني من
استهدافي شبه جزيره القرد مضيفه ان اي
استهدافا لمواقع روسيه باسلحه امريكيه
بعيده المدى سيدخل الصراع في مرحله جديده
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القوميه الروسيدي
متر ميدفيدف كان قد حذر من مساعي الغرب
لتسليح اوكرانيا باسلحه ثقيله وانظمه
هجوميه وقلم ادفيديف في بيان له انه على
القاده الغربي ادراك وان خساره قوه
النوويه مثل روسيا في حرب تقليديه ستؤدي
الى اندلاع حرب النوويه واضاف مدفيدف ان
روسيا لن تخسر صراعا يتوقف عليه مصيرها
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سرجيله بروف شدد من
جهته على ان بلاده هو بيلاروسيا مستعدتان
لمواجهه اي تهديدات متهما الغرب بدفع كياب
الى ارتكاب افعال خطيره ضد موسكو وميسي
واشار لابوروف خلال اجتماعه مع الرئيس
البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكا في ميمنس الا ان
التعاون الثنائي في المجال الدفاعي يجعل
من الممكن مواجهه اي تهديدات والاستعداد
لاي طوارق واكد لابروب انا روسيا وبيلا
روسيا بذلان جهود المشتركه لحمايه شعبهما
من اي عدوان المحتمل من الدول الغربيه
سفير روسيا لدى الولايات المتحده اناتولي
انتونوف قال ان الجيش الروسي سيرمر اي
اسلحه
ترسلها الدول الغربيه الى اوكرانيا مضيفا
ان ظهور دبابات تحمل رموزا نازيه على
اراضي الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا حسب وصفه
يدفع الكريملين الى الاطاحه بنظام
النازيين الجدد في اوكرانيا بشكل نقاطع
وفق ما افادت به وكاله تاس الروسيه للاباء
وشدد ايضا على ان تزويد الولايات المتحده
او دول النيه لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه لن يؤدي
الى زياده الخسائر البشريه بين المدنيين
وخلق صعوبات اضافيه في الجمهوريه
السوفياتيه السابقه
مين بروكسل ينضم اليه لمزيد من المتابعه
الدكتور بدي الامرابطي وهو مدير معهد
الابحاث والدراسات العليا في بروكسل دكتور
اهلا وسهلا بك ديمتري بيسكوف وفي تصريح
واضحا اليوم يؤكد ان امداد النيته كيف
باسلحه حديثه سينقل الحرب الى مرحله جديده
نوعيه وسيهدد الامن الجماعي الاوروبيين
كافه هل تعتقد ان هذه مجرد تهديدات كلاميه
ام لا الامور ذاهبه باتجاه التصعيد اكثر
فاكثر
يبدو ان فقدنا الاتصال مع الدكتور بدي لنا
عوده اليه فور جهوز الاتصال مجددا
الجيش الاوكراني اكثر من 270 صاروخا
وقذيفه مدفعيه استهدفت مدينه دونتس خلال
ال 24 ساعه الماضيه ومن الجانب الروسي
اعلن قوته السيطره على بلده تكشفكا
الواقعه على اطراف باخمد في الوقت الذي ما
يزال القتال العنيف مستمرا بين الجانبين
في ضواحي ضخمه وافاد مراسل العربيه بان
الجيش الروسي هاجم مواقع للقوات
الاوكرانيه في مدينه الشرق جنوب غربي
مقاطعه لوغانس نحو مدينه في الجروبكا غرب
الضامبرس التي ما تزال العمليات العسكريه
مستمره
الهجمات الروسيه لتوسيع الطوق حول الجيش
الاوكراني في مدن شمال وصولا الى باخ موت
وتوجيه الضربات للجيش الاوكراني من نواحي
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
نشاطنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
حركه اضرابات واحتجاجات كبيره في فرنسا ضد
خطه الرئيس الفرنسي لتاجيل سن التقوى
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعود الى من قطع من حديث من
بروكسل مع الدكتور وهو مدير ابحاث
والدراسات العليا في بروكسل دكتور بدي كنت
قد سالته
وفي تصريح واضح ان اليوم يؤكد ان امداد
باسلحه حديثه سينقل الحرب الى مرحله جديده
نوعيا
وسيودد الامن الجماعي الاوروبيين كافه هنا
بيت القصيده يعني هل تعتقد ان هذه مجرد
تهديدات كلاميه ام لا الامور ذاهبه باتجاه
تصعيد الحرب كما نوعا وحتى امتدادها
جغرافيا
لقد يتفق مع سيناريوهات
ناكل فقط اغلب اعتقد كل التي ظهرت هنا في
امريكا الشماليه منذ اشهر
اوكرانيا الى حد ما يسير باتجاه احد
السيناريين التقليدي
ان تتمكن اوكرانيا
وفي هذه الحاله السيناري والاكثر استخدامه
وعلى الاقل اكثر
منها بشكل استخدام
يعني تحديدا بشكل عام انا على السائده في
الدول العربيه
هو يقول ان الامن الجماعي الاوروبيين
سيكون مهددا تماما في حال تم تشريح كيف
بهذه الاسئله
وهنا السؤال عن امكانيه اتساع رقعه الحرب
لتتجاوز اوكرانيا والحديث بتعرف في كثير
من المواقع منه بولندا قد تكون في حال جرى
ازعاج الروش باسلحه همم غربيه متطوره جدا
قد تشعر همم موسكو بان ان القومي مهدد
اخوك ما تعرف في تقريبا اجماع كامل لان
روسيا لا يمكن ان تخثر هذه
لا يمكن ان تسمعها بخساره هذه الحرب في
اسباب الخاصه
او ان تقرر ميسي في الاستخدام الجزئي
للسلاح انه هو ومن يعمل
بصير وهو ان روسيا ثلاث اشياء روسيا
اقتصاد من الغرب روسيا
عسكر من مستوى التقليدي في منافس الى حد
ما نديه مع الغرب روسيا مناعيا نوويه في
التفرد على الغرب مباشره
استخدم سلاح الصعيد العالمي ولكن بشكل
محدود
لما تقوله دكتور بدي يعني ديمتري
مدفادف رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
يقول للغرب على القاده الغربيين ادراك ان
خساره قوه نوويه مثل روسيا في حرب تقليديه
سيؤدي الى اندلاع حرب نوويه طيب السؤال هل
يدرك الغرب بذلك هل يدرك ان ياته ذلك
بمعنى انه اذا حشرت موسكو في زاويه ضيقه
فان ذلك سيفلت النووي الروسي من عقاله
يحصل في جده اوروبا
انت عارف منذ 153 والله يعرف سنوات
الى الصين الى اسيا الى مختلفه ولكن من
ناحيه الميزانيه اي انتصار ولو جزء كبير
اوكرانيا سيشعب روسيا مضطره
كبيره
الولايات المتحده لا يمكن ان تقضي عليها
بروكسل دكتور بدي امراته مدير معهد
الابحاث والدراسات العليا في بروكسل شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
في شان اخر الاتحاد العراقي لكره القدم
المباراه النهائيه لبطوله الخليج العربي
ستقام اليوم بين منتخب العراق وسلطنه عمان
في موعدها المحدد الساعه السابعه مساء
بتوقيت العراق في ملعب البصره الدولي
الى عدم الحضور لملعب المباراه الامتلاء
مدرجاته بالكامل قبل نحو سبع ساعات من بدء
المباراه وذلك من اجل تنظيم المباراه
خليجي خمسه
يعني تسير الامور على خير ما يرام مش
عارفين هنالك عواطف
جمهور عراقي يعني اتكلم عن اكثر من نصف
مليون مواطن يعني بسؤال وما خارجها كانوا
في الاتجاه الى مشاهده المباراه الان يعني
بدات تفاهم الكثير منهم بداوا بالانسحاب
طبعا همنا هو داخل ملعب
مضبوطه
والمستطيل الاخضر
بشكل المثالي وحتى موضوع الضيوف الخارجيين
والشخصيات ايضا سوف يكون في موقعه وفي
مكانه ان شاء الله كل التوقيتات سوف تسير
حسب لها
الازدحام امام ملعب جذع النخله في البصره
كان قد ادى الى تدافع اسفر عن جرح 80
مشجعا وذكر مراسل العربيه انا ما لا يقل
عن 150,000 مشجعتشدوا خارج ملعب جزاء
النخله بينما دخلت اعدادهم كبيره الى
البصره منذ ليله امس بلغت اكثر من نصف
مليون شخص ولم يتمكن الامن من السيطره
عليها
معي من البصره الان لمزيد من المتابعه
مراسل العربيه سامر الكبيسي سامر اهلا
وسهلا بيك جديد المشهد من عندك قبل اقل من
ساعه ونصف الساعه على بدل مباراه النهائيه
وهل الامور تحت السيطره تماما
في البدايه مساء الخير الطالب عدنا قبل
قليل من ملعب جذع النخله حيث كان يتواجد
الكثير من الجماهير الامور الان تحت
السيطره بحسب القوات الامنيه التي التقينا
بها هناك انسحبنا من ملعب جذع النخله
وصولا الى منطقه المشجعين التي نتواجد
فيها الان طالب تستطيع ان تراه هناك تنظيم
صحيح ان المكان اصغر بكثير مما اا عليه في
ملعب جذع النخله لكن هناك تنظيم حتى عندما
كان الانسحاب جذع النخله باتجاه الساحات
والملاعب التي هياتها الحكومه المحليه في
البصره وذلك طبعا همم من اجل سحب الزخم من
هناك وتوزيع يعني الجماهير على مختلف
الساحات هنا الاجواء الاجواء ايجابيه جدا
جميعا ينتظر المباراه بفارق الصبر نحن
نتحدث عن جمهور من ساعات الصباح لمده
ساعات الصباح الاولى يتواجد في الملعب وفي
تلك الساحات المنتشره طبعا في عموم
رفضت البصره اضافه طبعا طالب لما موجود
حتى في العاصمه بغداد هناك بعض من الساحات
خصصتها الحكومه العراقيه للمشجعين لمتابعه
هذه المباراه العراقيون ياملون بان تنتهي
هذه البطوله على خير ويكون طبعا الكاس
عراقي كما يتمنى الجمهور هنا على الرغم
مما حدث طبعا في ساعه الصباح الاولى
الطالب
لو سمحت
من هذه المناسبه الكبيره هو التدافع الذي
حصل صباحا وسقوط عدد من الضحايا اول شيء
اخر حصيله اذا كان لديك معلومات وقيل انه
عدد من الجرحى حالتهم خطيره الى ان هذا
صحيح ام لا هذه مبالغه
فعلا طالب
استقينا بعض المعلومات من المصادر الطبيه
الموجوده في البصره حاله وفاه واحده مسجله
حتى الان لكن لم تعلن وزاره الصحه
العراقيه او حتى وزاره او عفوا مديريه صحه
البصره لم تعلن بشكل مباشر لكن هي من
مصادر الطبيه غير رسميه اكدت ايضا ااه
وجود اكثر من 80 اصابه ربما وصولا الى 100
اصابه البعض من الاصابه لم تسجل لكن همم
طالب البعض من الاصابات هي اصابات حالتها
خطره بسبب التدافع وحالات الاختناق التي
حدثت همم طالب تتحدث عن تقريبا ربع مليون
مشجع وصل الى محافظه البصره والبعض يتحدث
عن نصف مليون همم شخص قد هو من كردستان
ومحافظات الوسط والجنوب وكذلك حتى محافظه
بغداد او العاصمه بغداد طالب الامور يعني
خرجت عن السيطره في بعض الاوقات لكنها
سرعه ما عادت بسبب يعني طبعا وجود الق
الابنيه التي فرضت اطواقا هناك للحد من
وصول الجماهير التي لا تملك حتى البطاقات
والبعض هناك ايضا طالب همم غس لدى بعض
الجماهير الذين جاؤوا من المحافظات
واشتروا البطاقات وصلت البطاقه الى تقريبا
120$ امريكي همم
قبل ان قبل ان ننهي لو سمحت يعني اول شيء
ما هي التوقعات لهذه المباراه يعني في حال
فوز المنتخب العراقي نتمنى التوفيق للجميع
وما هو البرنامج المتوقع يعني همم في حال
فوز المنتخب العراقي باختصار
طالب توقعاتي ولا توقعات الجمهور اول شيء
توقعاتك انت ههه
امنيه بان يفوز منتخب العراق لهذه البطوله
خاصه
كثيرا يحتاج الى فرحه خاصه يعني انت تتحدث
عن مئات الالاف بل ربما الملايين ينتظرون
اي فرحه وعاده الافراح في العراق افراح
رياضيه وليست سياسيه واقتصاديه كما تعلم
لكن ايضا يعني الجميع هنا فائز ان كان
المنتخب العماني او المنتخب العراقي جميع
يتحدث عن فوز العراق باستضافه هذه البطوله
وتقريب يعني همم العراقيين تقارب
العراقيين وبالتالي ايضا حتى تقاربهم مع
المحيط الخليجي تشاهد السيارات الكويتيه
السعوديه القطريه البحرينيه تجوز هنا في
شورع البصره ربما هذا هو النجاح والفوز
الحقيقي
من البصره مراسل العربيه سامي الكبيسي
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك سامر على كل هذه
المتابعه
قال مسؤولون امريكيون لصحيفه جورنال ان
اجراءات الفيدره الامريكي لمراقبه حركه
الدولار بالمصارف العراقيه تهدف الى جعل
النظام المصرفي العراقي ممتثلا لممارسات
تحويل الاموال العالميه ومنع جهات خبيثه
من استغلال واضاف المسؤولون الامريكيون
للصحيفه ان النظام المصرفيه العراقي تم
استخدامه في تهريب الدولارات وكماذن لغسل
الاموال الى طيران مدينه
الاجراءات الجديده تم حضره 80%
او اكثر من تحويلات الدولار اليوميه الى
العراق والتي بلغ مجموعه اكثر من 250
مليون دولار
واكد مصرفيون عراقي
ان مستوردين قاموا بتزوير فواتير بضائع لم
يتم تسليمها ابدا الى العراق
وتدفقت بالدولار الى مستلمين مجهولين خارج
البلاد وقال مسؤول بالبنك الفيدرالي
الامريكي للصحيفه ان هناك نظام تتبع قويا
للحسابات العراقيه ويتطور بمرور الوقت
استجابه لمنع تهريب الدول
بحث وزير الخارجيه وداخليه ايطاليا مع
رئيس قيس سعيد مساله الهجره غير النظاميه
وضروره اعتماد مخالبه شامله لهذه الظاهره
وقد كانت 23 22 الاسود خلال العشريه
الاخيره وفق منظمات غير حكوميه خصوصا من
حيث عدد المهاجرين المفقودين في البحر
المتوسط
ابن عروس استقبلتنا السيده لطيفه حامله
صوره ابنها بين يديها وتخنقها العبارات في
حديثها عنه هي واحده من الاف الامهات
اللائكته
تعود الى 12 سنه خلف عندما ركب ابنها صبري
احد قوارب الموت رغم تحصيله شهاده جامعيه
ومنذ ذلك الحين وهي تنتظر عودته
حاشي بودي ولو معاه
الانتظار صاحبي
المتوسطي احلام جولي التونسيين الباحثين
عن مستقبل افضل احلام
الموت والهجره غير النظاميه جثث الالاف من
اصحابها في واحده من اقصى قصص المعاناه
الانسانيه التي قد لا تكفي المعالجه
الامنيه لايجاد حل لها قصه صبري والاف
المهاجرين غير نظامين تؤرق السلطات
التونسيه ونظيرتها الايطاليه وزير
الخارجيه والداخليه الايطاليين يحلان
بتونس وعلى طويله النقاش مع المسؤولين
التونسيين هذا الملف شائك امام رشح فهو
ضروره اعتماد مقاربه شامله لهذه الظاهره
تتجاوز البعد الامنيه
للهجره اكدنا مجددا انه يجب معالجته هذه
الظاهره من جذورها المشكله ليست امنيه فقط
رغم انها كذلك
يجب فهم الاسباب التي تدفع الالاف والالاف
لمغادره بلدانهم نحو الضفه الشماليه من
المتوسط وارغم هذه التاكيدات الرسميه تتهم
منظمات المجتمع المدني المعنيه بملف
الهجره تتهم سلطات التونسيه ونظراتها
الاوروبيه بعدم البحث عن اسبابها العميقه
وتوفير الاطر والاليات المناسبه لمعالجه
الظاهره
من السلطه خاصه الايطاليه
للحراسه
يعني هؤلاء الشباب والشابات
وبلغه الارقام وصل 18000 تونسيه السنه
الماضيه الى سواحل الايطاليه فيما بلغ عدد
الواصلين خلال نصف الاول من يناير الحاليه
اكثر من الف و 1700 شخص وليد عبد الله
العربيه تونس
تاتين مباشره من باريس اعزائي المشاهدين
حيث تنظم النقابات الفرنسيه اضرابات
واحتجاجات كبيره في العاصمه وفي مدن اخرى
ضد خطه الرئيس الفرنسي
لتمديد سن التقاعد من خلال مطرحهم برنامج
الاصلاحيه هذه الصور مباشره من المقرر
ايضا طرح مشروع القانون الجديد على
البرلمان لرفع سن التقاعد الرسمي من 62
عاما الى 64 عاما
بموجب المقترحات التي حددتها رئيسه
الوزراء الفرنسيه في وقت سابق من هذا
الشهر
سيتعين على الاشخاص من عام 27 العمل
للتاهل للحصول على معاش تقاعدي كامل مقابل
42 عاما كما هو معمول به الان اذا هذه هي
مشاهد مباشره من العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
لهذه الاضرابات والاعتصامات للنقابات
الفرنسيه خصوصا عمال المتر
تبع وسائل النقل الفرنسيه كذلك شهدت
اضرابات كبيره تعطلت حركه المترو حركه
المرور بشكل كبير ااه اضراب للسائقين همم
بدعوه من النقابات هذه هي المشاهد لهذه
الاضطرابات وهذه الاعتصامات والتظاهرات
الكبيره والحاشده جدا سواء في العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس وفي مدن فرنسيه
تم الغاء القطار ولن استطيع انجاز العمل
الذي كان علي القيام به اليوم لذلك امون
ان يكون كل شيء على ما يرام وان تكون هناك
حافله في مدينه حتى اتمكن من التنقل الامر
معقد للغايه بالفعل حيث تم الغاء جميع
القطارات في تقريبا
كان الامر صعبا للغايه اعيش في الضواحي
وكان القطار متاخرا بعض الشيء وخصوصا
المترو
اؤيد الاضرابات انها تعبير عن عدم الرضاعه
عن قرار الحكومه
نشاط الخامس مستمره في ايضا
نجوم الهلال والنصر يواجهنا باريس سان
جيرمان استاذ الملك فهد على بطوله كاس
موسم رياضه
اهلا بكم جديد تتسابقوا شركات التكنولوجيا
الكبرى في تقليص عدد الموظفيها حيث اعلن
شركه مايكروسوفت عن تسريحه 10,000 موظف
بنسبه انخفاض 5% من موظفي الشركه اما شركه
امازون فكانت الاعلى من حيث عدد الموظفين
المسرحين وذلك باكثر من 18,000 موظف
سي ام بي سي تسريحه شركات التقنيه
لموظفيها الى مخاوف من ركود اقتصاديا
محتمل هذا العام
الان الى زياد واخبار الرياضه لك يا زياد
[موسيقى]
شكرا يا طالب واهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
تشهد مدينه البصره العراقيه اليوم
المباراه النهائيه لبطوله كاس الخليج لكره
القدم والتي تجمع المنتخب
ويسعل المنتخب العراقي للتتويج باللقب
للمره الاولى منذ العام 88 بما توجد عمان
ولقب اخر مره في العام 2017 ونجح العراق
بالفوز بلقب ثلاث مرات مقابل مرتين لمنتخب
عمان
يلتقي الليله باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي مع
نجوم فريقيا النصر والهلال من السعوديه
وذلك في اطار موسم الرياضه وستقام
المباراه على استاد الملك فهد الدولي
المباراه ستكون الاولى للبرتغاليه
كريستيانو
رونالدو منذ انتقاله الى نادي النصر
السعودي
وسيتولى المدرب الارجنتيني مارسيلو جايادو
الاشراف على فريق نجوم الهلال والنصر
اهوال المزيد معنا من العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض مراسل العربيه نايفه ثقيل نايف
مساء الخير اهلا بك معنا وكيف الحضور
الجماهير نايف حتى الان
نحن في
[موسيقى]
المنطقه عاده زياد في
المباريات في استاد الملك فهد يكون هناك
فصل ما بين جماهير الهلال وجماهير النصر
لا تلتقي في المنطقه المحيطه في المدرجات
ولكن اليوم يعني قصدنا عدد كبير من
الجماهير والنصراويه التي ستكون جنبنا الى
جنب اليوم في هذه المباراه دعما لف لكي
الهلال والنصر المباراه اليوم صلاح حماسيه
ومن نوع يعني همم نادر صراحه حصل هنيه
بالرياض
مع بعض
وهلال نصراوي وكلنا واحد بعد المباراه هذه
يصير خير نتاهل
لا يا ايسا سجل هدف تتحمل لا اكيد اتحمس
اليوم فريق موسم الرياض مو بس هلاله ناصر
سالم وان شاء الله بيسجل الدهون تلسكه
الدوسري ان شاء الله كلهم سالم الدوسري ان
شاء الله مختلفتوا الحين ها ولا قلت ولا
لا لا ان شاء الله ان شاء الله ان شاء
الله ان شاء الله يعطونا يقدمون افضل ما
عندهم كل لعيبه يكون هلالي يكون نصراوي
وان شاء الله الكاس اليوم بالرياض يبقى
بالرياض ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
ميسي ميسي
بدا يعني يكون ضائع على الجماهير الحاضر
اليوم للمباراه التاريخيه والمنتظره اليوم
من العاصمه السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه شكرا
جزيلا
انتر ميلان بلقب كاس السوبر الايطالي لكره
القدم بعد تغلبه على جاره ميلان بثلاثه
اهداف دون مقابل في المباراه التي اقيمت
في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضيه دعنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
السوبر الايطاليه عاد الى العاصمه الرياض
هذه المره ميلان في مواجهه جريمه انتر في
استاد الملك فهد وليس سانسيرو
[موسيقى]
اميره
من اجل تعميق الفارق الانترنت
وعشر دقائق كانت كيفيه امامه لهز الشباك
عبر فريد
الا بعد مراجعه غرفه
هدف مبكر ازعج فيولي على خط التماس
واليوم ويقود هجمه سريعه لكنه اختار الحل
الفردي والتسديد وهنانا يبعد الكره
للركنيه
وعرف كيف يصل مره اخرى للمرمى منافسه وهذه
المره بهجمه منظمه انهاها المخدره
ملبوسنجيكو في الشباك
اكثر مع مرور الدقائق وكذا يقبل اهدافا
اخرى امام وهذا المشجع في المدرج
وحتى تسديده تموري افتقدت للدقه اللازمه
ينتهي الشوط الاول بتقدم
بتوصياتنا من مدربه ركز لاعب ميلان في
الشوط الثاني على تسديد من خارج منطقه
الجزاء لكن التي تمكن من تقليس النتيجه
كره قويه
قويه قويه قويه بعدها كل مدربين قام
بتغييرات التي يراها مناسبه لحسم المباره
لصالحها
جيدا وعرف كيف يؤمن فوقه بهدف ثالث الفنيه
[تصفيق]
رقم ميلان بسبعه كؤوس
في دوري 16 لمسابقه كاس ملك اسبانيا لكره
القدم يلتقي الليله برشلونه مع مضيفه فريق
سبته وسيدخل الفريق الكتالوني هذه
المباراه بمعنويه عاليه خاصه بعد فوزه على
ريال مدريد في كاس السوبر الاسباني ويتصدر
حاليا الترتيب العام للدوري الاسباني لكره
القدم
هو تاهل فالنسيا الى الدور مسابقه كاس ملك
اسبانيا لكره القدم بعد فوزها على مضيفه
سبورتنج خيخون باربعه اهداف دون مقابل
ونجح فالنسيا بالتسجيل عند الدقيقه
العاشره عن طريق اللاعب كافاني واضاف
الهولندي الهدف الثاني لفريقه في الدقيقه
الحاديه والعشرين وعاد كباني واحرز هدفه
الثاني والثالث لفريقه قبل سته دقائق من
نهايه الشوط الاول واكمل لينو رباعيه
فالنسيا في الشوط الثاني من هذه المباراه
ضمن الجوله الرابعه عشره من الدوري
السعودي لكره القدم يستقبل الاتحاد ضيفه
الفيحاء في جده بعد قليل حصيله الفريق
الجداوي وصلت الى 28 نقطه في المرتبه
الثالثه مقابل خمسه عشره نقطه للفيحاء في
المركز الثاني عشر
تعادل نادي الاسماعيلي مع طلائع الجيش
بهدف لكل منهما ضمن الجوله الرابعه عشر من
الدوري المصري لكره القدم الدقيقه الخامسه
اعلنت عن اول اهداف لقاء لمصلحه الجيش
وادرك الاسماعيلي التعادل عن طريق فراسه
شوات في اللحظات الاخيره من زمن اللقاء
بهذه النتيجه ارتفع رصيد الاسماعيلي الى
ثمان نقاط في المركز الاخير ورصيد الجيش
الى 14 نقطه حتى الان في الدوري المصري
لكره
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك طالب
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]